to me leadership starts with every CEO
or leader understanding they're actually
in the HR business comma they do other
things when I say in every all Hands-On
meeting which is often my inbox is open
email we will schedule 5 10 15 minutes I
think a lot of leaders don't realize how
much can be done in seven minutes we did
a huge creative offset on Monday and I'm
making such detailed nuanced reference
points in the meeting and a lot of the
creators have never worked with me and
they were just baffled by why I knew
that and a couple of them had the
courage to come up to me during breaks
and like why do you even know like how
do you know that because I talk to the
people that work here